so yeah hi everyone uh i'm tho adul
bakery i'm the head of new markets for
eo charging
if it's not obvious already i'm here to
talk to you about electric vehicle
charging
um and really it's just to tell you a
little bit about what we do in the space
uh what we'll be doing going forward uh
me personally taking this international
so we're a small international small
business that's local but really taking
on the world right now
and hopefully might even inspire you a
little bit to get involved with the ev
sector um so a little bit about us i
guess before we get into the nice
nitty-gritty stuff um our story is
really we're only a young company both
in terms of employee age but also how
long we've actually been up and running
so the business was founded by charlie
jardine who's a local boy from stone
market and he founded the business and
his granddad's pictured as the story
goes um just really wanted to take on
the existing incumbent kind of eevee
people in the market
um wanted to do something a bit more
young modern fresh and really take on
the big boys that have found you know
backed by shell and all these big guys
and really bring something new to the
table make something nice and sleek
but read this simple and kind of get
back to its roots
at the end of the day a charger is just
a charge there is no need to make it
more complicated than it needs to be
um but we've kind of grown very rapidly
since then so i joined probably about
two years ago now november 19.
i was employee number 3132 now we're up
250 plus in just over you know 18 months
or so
and we've probably got about 40 50
vacancies right now so you might see us
all over the place and next year we've
got another 100 to 200 more people
coming in
as we take on the world like i say
so
i guess let's move this on
so what you'll see on here is probably a
bit of a corny statement
we don't just power electric vehicle
with our people but to be fair it's kind
of true i'm evidence of that so i'm
currently head of new markets but i've
had about four or five different titles
inside joint
and that's because we we like to empower
people to just bring in their own ideas
change change the world ultimately
that's what we're doing in the ev space
but it doesn't just go for us it goes
for our customers as well so we build
new things we invent things for new
concepts new ideas and that's all
brought about by our own people so i'm
one of those
but also our customers come in and again
talking back about the incumbent people
that are in the market
they want to say this is how we do
things take it or leave it whereas most
of our customers come to us and say we
know what we're doing this is how we
operate our fleet our vehicles we need
to know how you can make it work for us
and that's our that's the general vibe
that we'd like to give off to our
customers we want to make it work for
them
so what do we actually do i mean i've
got a bit of a demo there you guys can
see but we cover a few different sectors
so homes fleets workplaces and
destinations
mostly focusing on fleets today because
really that's the interesting stuff but
i'll go through some of these so you got
an idea so home is obviously home
charging
really enough said about that you plug
your carrying overnight once you get
home
you get a full charge by the morning no
508 at the petrol station ideally
and now i guess our gig on that on in
the home space is it's a small
discharger on the market very popular
it's there on the table there it's about
the size of an a5 piece of paper no need
for a massive washing machine on the
side of your wall it needs to be hidden
really we don't want to be seen which is
kind of contrary to what most people
like to do
we want to be out of the way the whole
point is it enables you to drive a car
we don't want to be there in your face
you don't want to be advertising it it
needs to be nice and small
fleets i'll come back to but workplaces
and destinations really it's the same as
what you've seen outside there we've
actually got our chargers on the on the
walls and on the post
uh it's really where you put a charger
where you need to be really so wherever
you're gonna go and park for a couple
hours we'll have our chargers up there
really modular we've got a few with
co-op already going on the wall so if
you're going shopping you plug in for a
couple hours
and get that top-up that you need
because obviously if you're plugging in
at home you're fully charged anyway
so really going to a workplace cinema
restaurant is just a top up rather than
enabling you to move
and fleets for us i'll come to this in a
second it's not just cars and vans
and for us fleece is any business that
runs a large amount of vehicles and it's
critical to their operation
so a good example might be british
airways um a fleet of airplanes is also
a fleet and soon airplanes will be
electric dhl have already ordered 10
electric airplanes and we'll soon be
looking at that as well
but really what i want to focus on is
buses and trucks so it's been quite a
key area i've been leading that all year
it's a pretty new sector
there's only probably about 300 400
electric buses on the market at the
minute
in operation should i say mostly in
london obviously backed by tfl
and we're really getting involved in
that space to try and push it along
obviously as you've probably seen the
news recently that's really moving along
as well now it's getting a lot of
attention
but from our perspective fleets it
covers a wide range of things but as you
see on there depots and on route is what
we're calling it now so most
charging is done at the depot
your vehicle goes home to where it sits
it plugs overnight you take your car
home and you go home yourself
but the actual vehicle stays overnight
in the depot
on route though is something completely
new it's a new concept to electric
vehicle charging and that's where by you
start putting charges where the vehicle
is actually working
rather than waiting for it to get back
overnight to charge you charge while
it's actually operational
and we'll get through that as we go
through but just to give you guys an
idea
as to who we work with little old eo
from steel market now works with some of
the biggest players in the market and we
really enable them to do their work and
when they are all fully electric they're
really dependent on us to make their
entire business operation continue to
run and the biggest example of that is
big old amazon
the biggest
company in the world pretty much i think
um and not to sound like jeremy clarkson
um but they are going about
the biggest fleet electrification
project in the world um and we're lucky
to be enough to be lucky enough to be
their global partner for that so
currently well you might have seen
amazon have announced they've just gone
out and bought 100 000 electric vans
probably something that only amazon can
do to be perfectly honest but they went
out there bought it and said we're doing
this we're hitting it hard
and that's just for europe so they
bought a hundred thousand electric
buttons just for the european amazon
prime deliveries they've not even looked
at america yet they've not even looked
at the rest of the world they came to
europe because we are leading the way
and lucky for us they chose eo little
local suffolk based company to help them
do that
um i can't really show you too much
about amazon so i'll just talk about it
because it's all top secret but they're
happy for us to kind of go through it so
what we're doing for amazon and it's
really a big hot topic for video we talk
about it all the time because it's a
perfect example of what we do
for end to end so we make charges up in
stone market but that's just a very tiny
part of what we do
that's how we started and then again
going back to what i said earlier amazon
came to us and said we want xyz doing so
what that actually is is we've got our
own hardware but we want you to use
other people's hardware as well
so in essence they asked us to work with
our competitors and we no longer have
competitors we just have partners
so we're talking to people that make
other hardware that's abb alvin you
might have heard of various other
providers out there
we buy their products and we install
them on behalf of amazon as well so
we've got the hardware including third
party but we also do software for them
so
jeff bezos i know he's retired and
trying to go to space right now but i
use him as an example if he wants to log
in and see where all his vehicles are
and where all his charges are he can do
that
through the eo cloud so he logs in from
anywhere in the world and he can see
every single one of his charges see if
they're operational uh if it's being
used how much energy is being used
through it
but also he can also dial into the van
itself
probably a bit big brother who wants to
see if the guys having a mcdonald's or
not but you can actually see where the
van is in real time
where it is in relation to the charger
and just generally how it's going and if
if the charge is broken down he needs to
see that as well
but again all of this i've just
mentioned is still around about ten
percent of what we've actually done for
amazon because the big piece is actually
the installation i know it's been
mentioned briefly uh through other
people
but to give you a good example in a few
months time we'll be digging about three
miles up the road through the middle of
ipswich just to get power to the amazon
site on spartan road
and that's because they currently have
50 vans operational because the it's
connected to the actual building itself
and the building is limited on capacity
and power
so we are literally connecting into the
main primary substation for the entirety
of ipswich to bring the power that they
need to power a fleet of 600 vans
to that one site
bearing in mind they have a hundred
thousand fans on the way they only have
about two three thousand so far so
that's the level of scale that we're
talking about
we're literally changing
you know how everything operates in the
entirety of ipswich we're going to be
causing a bit of a mess a lot of traffic
by digging up three miles but it's it's
what we need to do and that's just
amazon we have various other customers
as you've seen and that's just one site
as well
and that's
it's this it shows you how much work
there is still left to do
um we've only just started on this
journey there's a lot of work still to
be done
but that's still not all so that's not
everything once we've installed
everything once we've caused that
carnage on the roads and installed
everything
it's still business critical
infrastructure so the charger works
that's great but it might not always
work
so what we also offer for the likes of
amazon is an o m service operation and
maintenance
um and for amazon they want a 90 minute
sla
which means if there's a fault we get
out to site within 90 minutes
an hour and a half any time of day any
day the year
christmas day sunday's included
so and that's because it's business
critical infrastructure when everything
is electric for amazon ironically we
have probably more power than they do
because if i log in and turn everything
off amazon no longer can operate
because their business is to sell you
stuff and deliver it to you and if that
van isn't charged then they're going to
do that
so we find ourselves again little ldo in
quite a powerful position with amazon
and all these other big companies
because if their vehicles aren't charged
they can't move they can't operate
absolutely critical infrastructure
so with that we need to
you know get out there fix anything and
to be honest we have to be there before
they do
we know what the problem is before they
even know it's occurred
so we have 24 hour surveillance
and we can see when the charges are
operational if they're not we'll try to
fix it remotely to be fair there aren't
that many problems but when there are
they're usually fixed by tenant off and
on again
it's it's one of those things but yeah
ninety percent of problems are solved by
doing that
if that's not possible we get outside
and just fix it
and we have to get very creative with
how we do that so you think about spare
parts
um access to them if we put something in
a corner and they lose it or worse yet
ship it to someone
we've just lost that spare part so we
have to figure out a way of doing it so
we've come up with all sorts of crazy
ideas again i can't really show you
pictures but literally having cages in
an amazon facility with a load of spare
parts in it so if anything was to happen
we can get there straight away our
engineers are all local so again amazon
ipswich is fed by local people but then
we do this across europe which are
probably not mentioned yet so everything
i've just mentioned we're doing on a
european scale we currently have three
and a half thousand charges across all
of europe but that's growing literally
daily um so we're literally three
percent of the way there we have a
hundred thousand vans we're at three
thousand or so
we still got 97 of the job to do and
again that's amazing alone
so
the reason i was talking about amazon
really is just to show you how big the
scale is i'll briefly touch on aviva is
another case study um i know we've
mentioned solar and that sort of thing
in previous talks
but to give you another idea as to what
we do
um this is aviva in perth in scotland so
they wanted to set about and create a
fully sustainable building
they wanted to do loads of solar car
ports so we did that as well and again
that's getting in the feedback from the
customers and say great we've got
charges but unlike amazon we don't just
want it from the grid
we want to you know have it fully
renewable so we want solar power as well
what they don't tell you is solar panel
solar power is useless um other than
during the day because you have to use
it immediately so if they have people
working 24 7 they try to get as many
people in these buildings as possible
you can't really plug your car in at
night
so then you've got to start looking
about batteries and that sort of thing
get the solar power during the day into
a battery use what you can during the
day and install the rest for the evening
so we look at all these different types
of different concepts and we're doing
something similar for the likes of
amazon as well because simply there's
some areas where there is no power in
the grid or it's going to cost millions
of pounds to actually get in there
so using those case studies once this
actually works there we go moving into
buses so everything i've just mentioned
is actually quite easy
when you compare it to buses so a
typical amazon van or a tesco's van or
in a car to a van they have around about
80 kilowatts of charge
a bus the smallest bus you're going to
get 250 kilowatts
but typically a double decker is just
under 400 kilowatts
so literally everything i've just
mentioned is easy because it's four
times as big on a bus
but there's one more thing and that's
that buses work on a lot shorter lead
times
so an amazon van gets back at 6 00 pm
and leaves at 6am that's a 12-hour
charge window
that's more than enough time to get it
fully charged even if you have no power
a bus gets back in at 10 pm it gets
cleaned and it's back out on the road at
2 2 am 3 am in some cases they never
stop
if they get back to depot they just swap
the drivers get a quick clean and
they're out on the road again
but if they're fully electric when are
you going to charge
so that's another challenge we had to
overcome dealing with these bus
operators and seeing you know how can we
actually make this work
the other thing with the bus is
obviously it's quite big with an amazon
van worst case you just take it home and
plug it in
if the depot is offline you're not going
to do that with the bus well i would
like to see that at some point and see
how that actually looks but yeah usually
bus depot is a crammed full of buses
i went the first one i went to i was
asked how many buses i think i can get
in there and i knew it was a trick
question so i said 50 and he was like
you're about 200 off
um so realistically i thought 50 buses
but they said no it's 252.
and that's why they get in a tiny bus
depot
but then we have to talk about charges
and where do i actually physically put
them do they pop out of the ground do i
drop them from the ceiling
because another thing we found out
talking to these guys is why don't you
just lose a bus and i'll put a charger
in his place
and he's like do you want to make 3 000
people unemployed because that one bus
is literally the margin i have that's
the profit-making vehicle
if i lose one i'm currently making a
loss and there's no point running the
business
so it's a really crazy situation to be
in when they're getting pushed
to be fully electric
but they have all these challenges that
are literally four or five times as
difficult as doing an amazon depot
without the budget
so we have to get quite creative with
what we do
and this is an example of what so we've
got the smallest charger on the market
right there but we're going to do the
biggest as well
so with buses you need to start being
very creative so one you try electrify
the depot as best you can
without removing vehicles and space
but then you have to get creative
because there's no other choice
so we started looking at on route
charging or opportunity charging as we
call it which is the pantograph there
that's actually in birmingham airport
and it's literally a bus stop
so the bus stops for five minutes to
pick up people and honestly drop them
off and move on again
but in that time it's gained 20 to 30
percent of the charge
and that's because there's literally a
village or a city's worth of power in
that charger
so at that charger there for home is
three kilowatts
what we're looking at here is 300
so just you know do the maths in your
head on that one but yeah what we're
doing is currently this isn't live yet
this is a single decker as you can tell
in three weeks time we'll be going live
with uk well not just the uk europe's
first double decker pantograph so
again a little eo changing the world um
so we've got that for go ahead who's
who's our biscuit amazon level client um
kind of going abroad with them i'll soon
be going to singapore and doing the same
thing for them
but yeah we've got the uh european well
the first ever double decker photograph
in europe
which is even bigger than the one that
you see there in the picture and again
the idea is the bus drives in
the charger lowers down onto the roof of
the bus which is where the connectors
are and it is literally blasted with a
village's worth the power in that time
and it gets 20 to 30 percent of the
charge
and the reason for that is this is
actually going in the depot itself so
it's going just on the outskirts as the
bus whisks its way out it stops five
minutes while the guy goes in and has a
cup of coffee and when he's out he's got
23 more charge now depending on the
route
some routes are longer than others
that might be just enough to finish the
route and get back home in the evening
to charge up
or it might be
a cost saving energy saving exercise
because if they have 20 30 percent more
charge at lunch when no one else is
using energy when they get back they've
got 20 to 30 percent more charge than
they would have done
which means there's more child or more
energy available for the rest of the
vehicles in the depot which means less
draw on the grid
and we'll soon start looking at the cost
and the cost of energy because when you
start looking at ev everything's going
to flip on its head
peak time currently is going to be
reversed
so peak time will be in the middle of
the night off peak is now
because no one's using energy if you're
all plugged in in the evening
and so are these guys then the grid is
just going to topple over so we have to
start looking at switching that and
literally flipping it on its head so
they do more charging during the day
when it's off peak
and also the prices are cheaper and
again when we talk about the margins
that these guys make one two percent
that might be the difference between a
viable product and just completely
shutting down the bus service
so in terms of what we do i've kind of
probably
covered that already but consultation
design delivery and support so
with these guys what we do again is it's
quite funny being a little older and
seeing it grow from you know 30 people
that it was when i joined and the
hundreds that it is now um we have to do
everything
because otherwise it just doesn't work
other people try get involved and you
get consultants and different people
involved but really it only really works
if you do the full thing
um i mean i've mentioned as a nip switch
there they went ahead and built the
depot and when they came to us we said
you probably shouldn't have built it
there
literally because they built it in the
worst possible place where there is no
power
and now it's going to cost you millions
of pounds for me to get power to you
because you've already gone ahead and
built it so again we're in a pretty
powerful position to say actually this
is what you need to do
we know you're big old amazon but you
need to listen to us
and we'll tell you how best to run your
fleet in a way but also obviously
working with them to figure out what's
best for them
so we do the full consultation piece
work out what their plans are where they
want to run their routes if they're a
bus or even the van for amazon
how they best schedule and deliver and
use that fleet obviously they're the
experts in this they move parcels they
move people but we're the experts in
energy and how to deploy it so it's a
it's a good marriage we have to work
together quite closely
we obviously then design so we talked
about design there digging three miles
of a road is is quite complicated so
you've got to go through all that stuff
but then you give them the electrical
drawings and everything they need to do
especially if they're building a brand
new site we're very involved in that
stage as well and we tell them where to
build and how to build it
or if they're too far down the line as
they often are because they run a
million miles an hour we have to try and
make it work
and in the case of a bus depot you have
to make it work because it's already
there and it's land they've bought that
was a tram shed 100 years ago and
they've just converted it so we have to
work with them as well as best we can to
give them the best design and then of
course deliver and support
which is you know the 90-minute service
that we sometimes have to offer
it's going to get a bit more difficult
when you've got the first of a double
decker pantograph to maintain it's a bit
more difficult than a van charger but
we'll get there
briefly go through our products but i'll
leave some time at the end for questions
so
that's not really showing up very well
on there but what we've got is
obviously that mini charger right there
our product is the eo genius as we call
it that's what we install for amazon the
idea is that it's a modular charger
so most charges you see on the market
have basically a brain inside every
single one which makes it incredibly
expensive
and really it's the thing that really
swung things in our favor when dealing
with amazon is that actually you have
one brain
we put it near to the power supply it
will read what your building is using
and then it will draw what available
power there is and give it to the
chargers that then share out between
them
but it's still one brain which means the
charger itself is very cheap
very replaceable and to be fair very
reliable there's nothing that can really
fault it's just a dumb charger that
pumps out energy hence why we never
really have any problems we've got 99.8
percent uptime but when there is a fault
we'll swap it because it's cheap and
we'll just cover the cost
that's why we've never been fined even
though we're covering a full european
scale deployment
and we're doing a 90-minute sla
we only need to allow an hour for an
engineer to get out there and it's a
10-minute job to swap it out
so we've never been fined because that's
what we signed up to if your charger
doesn't work your van doesn't work your
brand is damaged so we'll pay for that
but we've never done that we've never
needed to
so that's the eo genius it's a very
reliable piece of hardware but that's
not always possible so everything i've
mentioned with bus we don't actually use
any of our own products
it's literally the service side of
things that we offer so we use third
party that says ocpp which just stands
for open charge point protocol so any
charger that is
on that protocol we can work with it's
onboarded onto our software
so i mentioned mr bezos earlier he can
log in and see wherever charger that is
on his platform that is compliant
the chinese aren't so so good at that
side of things so we deal mostly with
european companies like abb in the
netherlands of several finnish and
norwegian companies who are
the scandinavian countries are very far
ahead in that
and then we've got the rapid charging of
the dc charges as you might know them by
and that's the the the double decker
pantograph we talked about obviously
very big products um but they can come
in all shapes and sizes as well you
probably would have seen quite a few on
the motorways
they tend to look like big american
style fridges but that's just the way it
is you have to squeeze a lot of
information and a lot of hardware in
there to make them work but nevertheless
we'll supply them and then we install
them and offer the exact same service
um again i've kind of covered this
already really but it's it's you know
what we offer on the software and
services side of things is that full
modern data driven aspect of things so
one you can schedule your charging so
that's actually quite a key one and i
mentioned earlier with off-peak and
tariffs and that sort of thing
when you plug in a vehicle you know the
guy who's doing his amazon deployment
he's out all day he wants to get home
and just plug his van in and go away but
that's not necessarily a bad thing the
best thing for amazon because currently
that's peak time
so it's not survivable but realistically
the van only needs three four hours of
charge
so what actually happens is they
physically plug in but it doesn't
actually click in to charge
the charge is only active activated
remotely
whenever it needs to be and that's
either preset or done manually and that
would be in line with the tariffs so
what we actually do is do live tracking
of tariffs
because those of you who might have
octopus or those sorts of providers the
tariffs will go up and down
so then the charger will click in only
whenever it's cheapest but while still
enabling 100 charge by the warning so
that we get quite creative with that and
as you can see there was with the cloud
and the software you can track the
vehicle as well so you can log in at any
moment in time and see which vehicle you
have on the road
and for someone like amazon that runs a
fleet that isn't just vans it's becoming
quite critical so they have buses as
well they have trucks they have all
sorts of articulated lorries that will
soon be electric as well so again mr
bezos can log in and see all right
that's a truck that's going to this
depot that parcel is going to go from
a smaller truck to a smaller truck and
then to a van
but it's all tracked in one system
and again that's across europe
um again just a bit of a closer upfront
image there for the actual cloud and
this is an example of the ectaro which
is a new mercedes vehicle that's coming
in so we do a lot of work with the oems
the manufacturers of the vehicles as
well and again little ldo's in quite a
powerful position now because they want
to work with us
because ultimately we work with all the
operators they might have different
types of vehicles and if their vehicles
aren't on our cloud then they're
probably not going to sell their vehicle
so again it's sort of flipped on its
head and we're getting inquiries from
left right and center from all sorts of
oem saying help me get onto your cloud
because otherwise go ahead or abella or
national express won't work with us
because it needs to be on there
a little piece there just on charging as
a service so we do a lot of finance so
most of these companies
um obviously don't have the budget
unlike amazon so we also help them out
with finance now again little oldio now
is financing very big projects in the
millions of pounds for very big
operators
so that can be done in various ways and
the most creative way that we've worked
out for people is
we've got a big multi-million pound
project but what you pay is per kilowatt
that you use
so we will finance that sometimes
internally sometimes with partners but
we'll take the big upfront capex cost
and turn it into opex so literally they
pay as they go they've had all the
infrastructure installed that might have
involved you know miles and miles worth
of digging and civils and that sort of
thing but ultimately they don't care
about that they just pay as they go
every kilowatt that they use will
discharge them on a per kilowatt basis
and that might be for 15 to 20 years it
depends on what kind of deal they want
another one that's pretty common is you
just simply chunk it down so you spread
the cost over five years ten years
whatever's best
and again that's just to make them
a bit more viable make the project more
viable if they're being forced by
councils or by tfl to go electric
i mean that project is quite expensive
but they also have the buses and the
vehicles themselves to buy which are
hundreds of thousands of pounds
so how can we make that transition
easier well we'll just chunk it up make
the finance a bit easier to handle
and finally just a piece on the oam i've
sort of mentioned this already with uh
with amazon but yeah always in safe
hands is the motto so regardless of what
hardware is it might be our own and
obviously it has its perks
um it might be third party or it might
be a completely new one that's never
been on the market before which is stuff
we're also doing that we're literally
helping people invent products
um we'll maintain it and service it
because that's ultimately the key thing
the hardware sort of becomes redundant
it's all it becomes business critical
infrastructure so it has to be
operational regardless of what it is
so the o m piece actually becomes more
important once it's in the ground it's
in the ground but we need to make sure
it works because otherwise we've just
killed your business
if you if your vehicle isn't charged in
the morning then that's it game over so
that's sort of the main thing for us
we've got an in-house dedicated team
that's pretty much where all the
vacancies are going at the minute is
continuing to grow that but then also
putting it into different languages so
we're working across europe already with
the likes of amazon we're going further
afield
into singapore and australia that
doesn't need a new language but you get
my point
so we're bringing in more and more
people to service these people uh
service these different countries in
different languages but still offering
the exact same service or level of
service to keep things going
and that's
kind of it for me really i thought i'd
just leave it up leave it open for any
questions for anyone or otherwise i'll
be on the panel a bit later as well
any questions
is there a micro
i can hear you
thank you so much for the presentation
um two questions one around charging as
a service has the uptake um
so don't no need to mention who but
between amazon aviva the big clients do
they accept um a service like this for
15 20 years
and second one you mentioned about dna
upgrades in the same slide yeah is dno
really charging for um
if you need a charging station sort of a
thing so do they then charge for the
upgrade yes so the answer is yes to both
i'll go into details so to be honest on
the on the finance piece
it's the idea was theirs not ours
so our service is here's the cost it
might be 100 000 million whatever it
might be 10k
and they come to us and say actually we
can't afford that we want to do it we
know we have to do it we we don't want
to go with anyone else
we want you to do it but we can't afford
it so what can you do to make it work
and that's where that idea came from
again goes back to the very first slide
we empower people just come to us with
ideas and that goes for everyone in the
room
so they came to us and said what if we
break it out over 14 years
and that was from a bus operator so the
reason for that is in tf in london in
tfl they work on a seven year contract
so they bid for a route literally w15
whatever it might be called and that
they just cycle that for seven years
so then they came to us and said can we
finance it over 14 years
it should be pretty obvious two terms so
upon seven year contract we'll still
have the vehicle but we'll use it on a
different route even if we lose the
second tender but can we finance it over
14 years
and we said
interesting idea let's have a look at it
so and that's what we did we took the
cost it was a very expensive job because
of the dno upgrade which i'll talk about
in a sec
and we financed that over 14 years so we
had to look at forecast we went into
very creative forecasting it's this is
the route this is how big the bus is and
that the kilowatts per hour in the
battery kilowatts per hour per mile and
then you work that all across the route
you spread that over 14 years and then
you break it down across the cost of the
job and you charge them either a 14-year
fixed fee which we did in this case
or in other scenarios we paid we charged
them per kilowatt
based on all those calculations that
were very complex and over my head so
that's kind of how that worked to answer
second question the dnl yeah that's the
reason for it so dnos to be honest are
very unhelpful
you've got uk pnround here which
actually is probably one of the more
helpful ones
mpg if you get into scotland absolutely
awful
they will take as long as they need to
or as long as they possibly can to get
back to you and they'll come back to you
with a full cost of reinforcing the
network so part of our service in that
consultation piece is actually being
quite aggressive and challenging the dns
so actually you've seen there it's
amazing and you're trying to get your
network reinforced at that cost
but we're not having that so we have to
get into these conversations and say
actually it's your network you need to
pay for some of it
and then amazon or the client will pay
for what they need to pay and that might
be a three mile long dig just to get the
cable from one point to the other so in
that scenario we're literally going by
the sainsbury's in
in ipswich and getting it all the way to
spartan road not off the not far off a14
uh connecting into literally amazon
sorry ipswich's main grid substation and
bringing the cable there but uk pn are
paying for an upgrade at felix though
so and that won't be done until 2023 so
that shows you the scale of these jobs
and that's just for 500 vans in one
place
so that's where we get into that
conversation the dnls do have to pay for
something as do national grid who is the
level above because they transmit all
the energy
but then there's an element that the
customer always has to pay for
um yeah thank you for the presentation
uh we actually already installed some of
your your charge points good to hear i
do like the little swan so just a little
plug there for you um but uh yeah the
question i've got is this is all
brilliant for all of the big
corporations but obviously sme is a 99
percent of the economy um the government
obviously have got these grants out for
um for home place charge schemes um but
they've now announced that the work the
home place sorry the workplace chelsea
but the home place child schemes have
stopped in march
now for a lot of smes where they don't
really want their employees coming to
come into a workplace for charging and
that's going to have quite a large
impact i wonder if you've got any
opinions on that
no well
i guess the honest answer is you've had
long enough to get one the grant's been
around for ages um but yeah it's
obviously going on it used to be 500
quid and now it's 350. so i guess my
advice on that is it's free money so
take it
uh get a charger installed as soon as
you can obviously i think our offer is
595 for a fully installed one with the
grant included um but yeah so general
statement get out there and do it
for the guys at home sorry for the smes
or people operating smaller fleets you
do get grants as well for workplace
charging i mean for amazon they've not
bothered because i think the caps 40k
and i've already mentioned one jobs
millions but for the smes we do a fair
bit of that as well so i can't remember
the exact numbers that they get because
it's forever changing and soon expiring
but yeah you'll also get i think a cap
up to 40k across your estate
for workplace charging and then
obviously the individual
will get the 350 off their home charger
what we do with that to make it easier
for the smaller companies especially or
even the amazons of the world
is through the software we make it quite
creative
so that when let's say a sky van or a
beta or a tesco's van goes home and he
wants to charge at home
the charger that one right there will
recognize whether it's a work vehicle or
a personal vehicle
and therefore the energy used which is
the guy's home energy or the person's
home energy
the bit that goes into the work vehicle
is actually recognized and then the
company pay for it seamlessly for
expenses and then obviously if they're
charging their own renault zoe or
whatever then that's that's paid for by
themselves as they would for their tv or
their kettle so that's the bit that we
tried to help out with but ultimately
for the cost of infrastructure is
there's been plenty of grants out
it's expiring so the honest answer is
get out there and get it installed
before you lose it otherwise you're
gonna be paying a lot more money
yourself
are you another question
thank you
peter gotti the great southeast energy
hub and shivali took my question around
the dnas
yeah 15 mva for a charge for 250 buses
is a bit scary so i understand you're
going to a good supply point skipping
out to dno um
my question is more about
those who can't afford to put charges in
and the electrification of
transportation particularly passenger
vehicles and the the potential injustice
and unfairness we created if we do move
to a world that doesn't allow charging
in rural areas for example or those
can't afford to charge
how could we locally facilitate that
with you
where there's a non-market-based
solution
well there's there's various
companies in that in the actual ev space
not necessarily as although we do enable
that
there's various public charges available
so public networks obviously there's a
lot of money to be made here being quite
honest so you've got a lot of private
equity firms and other pension funds and
that sort of thing that put the money
into
other businesses like instaval osprey
ecotricity ecosystem i've heard of grid
serve these guys are putting money in so
that they will actually take that cost
on and they sometimes pay millions
themselves for the dnl upgrades and
everything and then literally install
banks and banks of typically rapid
charges
and that's available so yeah taking
point if someone lives in a flat they
don't have a driveway they can't have a
charger they they will hopefully have a
charging network around them that they
can use
or otherwise you go back into the
workplace scenario those people will
surely be having a job somewhere or
they'll go to the restaurant or the
cinema or somewhere like that
and that will have charging facilities
open as well
i think to be fair to you to you guys
you guys need to get involved a bit more
so councils need to do as much as they
can really there's plenty of funding
available from the government but also
working creatively with either
businesses like ourselves or these
pension funds and other funders
available
to try put those charges and those
networks in at their cost and then
recoup them just as you would a car
parking space
so if someone goes to a car park instead
of paying you know two pounds per hour
or something like that they pay per
kilowatt that they use for the eb
charger again cost will obviously have
to be changed someone has to get the
money back somewhere
but i think that's probably the easiest
way that we do come across quite a few
people that want charges but they don't
have driveways so either they're not
eligible for the grant because the grant
says you need to have a driveway um or
they just simply can't have it because
where are you gonna park your car you
can't have a 10 meter long lead across
the pavement just to try and get you
your car plugged in so the solution now
there's there's all sorts of things
going in right now you've got chargers
popping out the ground in the road
that's a competitor ultimately connected
kerb
others that go in lamp posts
but i think that's you know it's it's a
very small market that you probably want
to get to the public charges so we do a
lot of work with the likes of ncp
public car parks again and they're
changing how they work there's a
question earlier about societal changes
and that sort of thing and that's he
changed habits and changed how people
actually work if you plug in or if you
go and park in an ncp anyway
they are changing how they work to
enable you to do that as well
so that you can go instead of paying you
know 10 pound per day or whatever it is
you pay per kilowatt that you use while
you're parked there and they'll recoup
the cost of you know operating the car
park through that means as well
but it is it is an interesting question
it's a challenging one it's something
that i think everyone needs to have a
proper think about and it's it should be
led by local authorities i think to
look after that side of the market on
that side of the the public charging
space